hello guys I'm Ryan right around five
four brown and I are gonna check out
fighter craps all over a cage mat during
fight do you think this is real it looks
like it
[Music]
stop stop
there's no
[Music]
what no way
[Music]
that's real no it is
oh [ __ ]
oh my gosh
[Music]
another
[Music]
so embarrassing
[Music]
I feel so sorry no I do too cuz he was
almost just like there's nothing I can
do about it
come on we've all pooped our pants
10news yeah I've been like three weeks
ago thought I was gonna fart poop came
out oh poor guy he's humiliated here we
are just showing the subscribers what
sorry I wonder how that happened he just
got twisted in the wrong way but it just
came like stomach better hurt there's
something he'd get that out before a
fight like that poor guy I feel so like
I would be cracking up so hard right now
if he had been like embarrassed
thanks yeah he was just like he felt
like it was just like I felt like he was
more sad that he just lost a fight not
so much about the [ __ ] yeah
cuz he looked at it he looked at it like
yeah and everybody I would have been
doing the exact same thing everybody was
taking my Instagram me too
oh man but I also would have said I feel
so sorry for him as I exploited oh
that's hysterical
and disgusting and humility it's like
it's a weird hybrid of I feel so sorry
for him and that is one of the funniest
things I've ever seen
it's the combination of it I had one
time when I was I was at Spring Break
Panama City all my girlfriends there was
like a booty shaking contest
I didn't do it but all the girls were up
there and this little like 4 foot 11
girl not me
was up there and she was booty shaking
and it kind of reminds me of this story
and Shh she had started her period
oh no yeah yeah and so that kind of
reminds me of that and it was almost the
same thing like I could I was just
watching like
but at the same time I wanted to like
yeah I understand I understand why do
you find that more gross than them
no no area can be more forgiving I think
yeah cuz that's natural not a very good
bill girls don't poop one time there's
another guy comes with channelling Dan
one time Dan was throwing a party like a
gathering and then I went to the
bathroom and dad did not flush your [ __ ]
I don't like it when people leave [ __ ]
in the toilet oh that is the worst the
worst sometimes when I'm babysitting I
used to be babysitting and I walk in to
go to the bathroom and I'd lift up the
toilet it'd be this beautiful little
three-year-old girl and I'd lift up the
toilet and they didn't remember to flush
because they're freaking three years old
and they just learned how to poop on the
toilet in the first place and I just
like couldn't go I couldn't go even that
was a beautiful three-year-old little
girl that like Oh a poop see in the
toilet and didn't flush
it was disgusting and I couldn't I
couldn't handle it yeah I hate that
flush the toilet the other time I really
put my pants was in second grade second
grade I really had to go teacher or to
let us go to the bathroom when a teacher
doesn't let you go to the bathroom that
is [ __ ] up that's the ultimate you
should not have to hold it that's when I
try and exercise my rights like who are
you to tell me what to do and it was
like storm out so why should my pants
and everyone was like what says smell
you're kidding and then the kids were
like he pooped his pants and then one
guy I was like let me smell your butt no
no he tried to but I didn't let him I
just told everyone I vomited no really
it's really embarrassing that really
that's a true story here all day did you
continue going to that school the rest
of yeah for like six more years it was a
first to eighth grade does anybody
remember it I don't think so I just [ __ ]
bothers me I don't like taking a [ __ ] in
someone's home like if it's a new home
person like new home like let's say I
went to your place for the first time
yeah yeah and then I found myself like I
gotta take a [ __ ]
I wouldn't do it would you do I just
hold it in and just let my stomach go in
pain
thank you thank you thank you I feel
that there's several people you have the
best map you like why am I offended I
don't understand anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the channel if you're new
to it you can subscribe today click this
button become a reject Oh bot that's my
word for the for the people that's cute
that's cute for your Autobot reject Oh
bot I'm like that's pretty cool yeah
yeah comes with anal beads and you could
check out Pfeiffer brown on Facebook
Instagram Twitter yeah
where she is other bikini photos yes are
there really think I am absolutely not
you started in a hot r-rated horror film
yeah I know so you have no morals
against violence and horror and terror
but when it comes to doing a natural
bikini phone our body is a temple you
ain't gonna see that on Facebook
I hope Meghan services may be helpful
stop sending pictures